[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est maintenant monsieur André
Richard pour le groupe les républicains
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre Christophe Béchu celui ministre
nous vous avons dans cet enceinte
plusieurs fois interpellé sur les graves
difficultés de
occasionnées par la hausse du coup de
l'énergie à la fois sur les particuliers
les entreprises mais également les
collectivités locales permettez-moi
aujourd'hui de revenir plus
particulièrement sur ces conséquences
pour les communes celle-ci ont bien
entendu engagé pour la plupart d'entre
elles au moins différents plans de
sobriété énergétiques dès l'année
dernière mais si les effets commencent
tout doucement apparaître ceci reste
naturellement minime par rapport à
l'impact exorbitant des charges
d'énergie sur le budget ou projet de
budget 2023 par ailleurs alors qu'elle
supporte totalement les nouveaux prix du
gaz le bouclier tarifaire pour certaines
l'amortisseur électricité et le filet de
sécurité ne suffisent naturellement pas
au maintien des équilibres financiers
précédents en effet l'explosion des
coûts de l'énergie outre ses
préoccupations directes à bien d'autres
effets induits sur d'autres postes des
budgets des communes telles les
augmentations des contrats de
maintenance des prestations de services
et bien d'autres ainsi il n'est pas rare
que de ce seul fait l'augmentation des
dépenses de fonctionnement d'une année
sur l'autre dans la préparation du
budget 2023 soit de l'ordre de 20% et
rendent impossible le vote d'un budget à
l'équilibre monsieur le ministre il
convient de tout faire pour encore mieux
accompagner ces collectivités locales en
2023 j'ai à cet égard deux propositions
à vous faire ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait utile de prononcer une
suspension temporaire pour 2023 du
prélèvement annuel que subissent un
grand nombre de communes de notre pays
pour insuffisance de logements sociaux
tels que le prévoit l'article 55 de la
loi SRU
j'ai bien dit suspension pour 2023
ensuite du fait de la hausse du coût de
l'énergie le montant de la TVA sur ses
factures s'envolent à du proportion dès
lors que les collectivités locales ne
peuvent pas récupérer cette taxe comment
leur éviter cette double peine
allez-vous les faire profiter en retour
des sommes ainsi perçues je vous
remercie de votre réponse c'est la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Richard
vous l'avez dit face à l'explosion de
ses factures énergétiques un certain
nombre de dispositifs ont été mis en
place je n'y reviens pas pour les plus
petites boucliers l'amortisseur pour les
autres et puis ces filets de sécurité au
cœur de l'été dernier avec le concours
actif de la majorité sénatoriale la fois
par rapport au montant et par rapport au
contour et puis dans le cadre de la loi
de finance avec un montant d'un milliard
et demi d'euros et des conditions qui
ont été assouplies que ce soit sur la
baisse de l'épargne ou que ce soit sur
la porte d'entrée du dispositif on est
au tout début de l'année les premiers
chiffres dont on dispose que je
considère comme n'étant pas signifiant
sur l'épargne et sur les dépôts auprès
du Trésor au 31 décembre on a plutôt une
progression des crédits mais on ne peut
pas à ce stade les détourer par strate
de collectivité et on sait que toutes ne
sont pas impactés de la même manière
deuxièmement le filet de sécurité on
n'en voit pas encore totalement les
effets puisqu'on est dans les premières
semaines on a eu des demandes au titre
de l'année dernière de plus de 4000
collectivités déclenchant plus de 100
millions d'euros de décaissement
au-dessus du dispositif 2022 mais le
milliard et demi qui est sur la table
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas dans quelle
mesure il va être utilisé ma priorité
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord qu'on regarde
rapidement
la réalité de la consommation
prévisionnelle de ce filet de sécurité
pour savoir s'il a été correctement
dimensionné vous faites des propositions
elles ont le mérite de se trouver dans
un esprit de co-construction mais j'ai
un peu de mal à comprendre la première
sur la suspension du prélèvement de
l'article 55 lié à la carence de
logements social parce que ça voudrait
dire que les communes qui ont plus de
25% de logements sociaux les aideraient
pas et que celles qui ont moins et qui
se retrouvent dans une situation
rattrapage celle-là bénéficierait d'une
aide ce serait quand même surprenant de
récompenser la carence au lieu de
récompenser celle qui au contraire on
fait en sorte de faire une partie du
chemin donc ma proposition elle est
simple à ce stade qu'on regarde
l'effectivité du filet de sécurité pour
mesurer s'il convient de la maudier de
le modifier puisqu'on a un engagement
budgétaire important